[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si la transaction est sûrs de nous ça
rigole ça c'est michael jackson ça ok
aux pirates je me suis dit mon frère
on dirait le cuisinier marc veyrat alors
on va faire du piment d'espelette
si ça veut dire très longtemps mais tout
ce soir
[Musique]
nous voilà
on va parler d'album live à l'infini
live tour et vous bien extrait du clip
like de votre reprise de ses champs
quand vous avez une tête comme ça vous
pensiez que des têtes comme ça on vous
parlait toujours mais on se croit je
sais qu'il ya on a une reprise de voile
habitable santé de michael jackson
c'était lors de votre de votre tournée
dans la presse regarder on à l'excès
voilà ma dans la poche genre beau gosse
d'accord si le mec est persuadé qu'il
est beau gosse santé vous pouvez
charrier 1 sur twitter et sur facebook
bien sûr allez vous regarder talent et
al
vous allez faire avec moi vous allez
apprendre la chorégraphie de michael
jackson on va se mettre au centre de la
scène
allez c'est parti regarde ça là pourquoi
pourquoi même michael jackson je parle
comme patrick sébastien sens et c'est
parti on y va regarder ça
le pays
bizarre
tu te bizarre et
[Musique]
m
suis tu
cours débutants et torchlight
[Applaudissements]
vous allez donc m'apprendre est donc à
prendre nos téléspectateurs 3 pas un de
michael jackson c'était trop plaisir
talent donc trois pas de michael jackson
va faire une chorégraphie ensemble très
conseillé de faire également chez vous
attention je suis avec vous c'est parti
alors je combats communs avec le monde
est déjà d'accord ok de moonwalk donc on
va se mettre de profit alors ok et donc
tu va reculer
ouais ils sont sales et déjà on va le
faire comme ça glisse en fait
et non je souhaite c'est compliqué c'est
bon alors ensuite on va fléchir les gens
7 mètres sur le côté regarde comme ça
vas-y voilà mais ta main oui la
maladroite la main droite ici la main
gauche leur étuver
ah oui pas mal à garder pas alors il ya
un saut avant le pas en fait pour que
l'irlande saut et aprilia on voit déjà
les attendent et vous mettrez la musique
après l'or alors tu fais le saut ouais
d'accord et direct après le saut m mais
t'es ouf bad et on enchaîne les trois
parts d'accor aux caisses ouvertes à
tous les deux ensemble donc on fait quoi
boules molles
après on fait le gros dos face et après
on fait un saut d'accord c'est bon je
les droitiers attention attention moi je
vous suis pas du tout où voulez vous
nous faites une chorégraphie sur metaxa
d'accord mais dites moi si vous suis
d'accord je fais tout ce que vous faites
attention c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non tout comme bien souvent la tête